[Musique]
ouvre la bouche
Clint Eastwood radio sur le monde du
cinéma depuis 60 ans
pourtant cet homme dont la terre entière
connaît le nom reste un mystère il
verrouille sa vie privée et attaque ceux
qui en parlent sans autorisation
son enfant sa vie son rapport aux femmes
ses engagements réservent bien des
secrets sur lesquels nous allons lever
un voile
la carrière de Clint a commencé au début
des années 50 à 20 ans lorsqu'il
débarque à Hollywood on utilise ce beau
gosse pour sa plastique avantageuse
mais il sait prendre des risques et
saisir sa chance pour devenir une
vedette et puis une star
[Musique]
à 40 ans c'est l'acteur le mieux payé du
monde
aujourd'hui Clint est un monarque dans
l'univers du cinéma
producteur il a amassé une énorme
fortune metteur en scène il est salué
comme un génie
[Musique]
pour comprendre ce monument nous allons
voyager vers les lieux importants de sa
vie
[Musique]
embarquons vers l'Italie ou le destin de
Clint Eastwood s'est noué en 1964
[Musique]
il n'était alors qu'une vedette de
télévision américaine lorsque le
réalisateur Sergio Leone est venu lui
proposer de tourner dans un spaghetti
western les premières scènes ont été
tournées ici
le film s'appelait pour une poignée de
dollars
le héros l'homme son nom deviendra culte
[Musique]
aujourd'hui nous retrouvons dans ces
studios mythiques l'écrivain américain
Patrick McGilligan auteur d'une
biographie très documentée
soucieux du contrôle de son image
Clint a intenté des procès pour la faire
interdire mais en vain
[Musique]
de Leon Leon ne savait rien de crinte il
ne lui avait pas parlé de son côté
l'agent de Clint pensait que c'était une
bonne idée
l'Amérique alors il a accepté ce boulot
en Italie et l'assistant de Sergio Leone
m'a raconté que Sergio était trop
nerveux pour aller l'accueillir à
l'aéroport il y a donc lui-même il l'a
conduit à son hôtel pour qu'il rencontre
Sergio Clint a ouvert sa valise et il
avait tous ses costumes pour le film le
boléro la couverture mexicaine
je ne sais pas pour le cigare parce que
Clint ne fume pas et les gens disaient
que c'était l'idée de Léone
mais il a dit que Clint était habillé
avec mauvais goût comme tous les
étudiants américains
mais il aimait son visage et sa façon de
marcher il lui a dit nous allons faire
un bon western ensemble
[Musique]
ne s'attendait à ce que pour une poignée
de dollars fut un des westerns les plus
importants de tous les temps
à Rome vit encore un témoin privilégié
de cette époque le scénariste des films
de Sergio Leone
il a aujourd'hui 87 ans il s'appelle
Luciano Vincenzoni
le jour après qu'il est arrivé il avait
lu
les scénarios du père que dollars en
plus
qu'ils avaient écrit par cette Léonie il
était très content de faire des films
pourquoi parce que jusqu'à ce moment-là
il était un petit acteur de télévision
et avec ce film il était les personnes
allaient protagonistes
physiquement il était parfait pour pour
la pérole personne au monde est capable
de
travailler avec la colle comme lui
il était formidable il faisait du
rapidité
j'ai fait des autres western avec des
autres acteurs jamais capable de perdre
si rapidement comme lui
[Musique]
qui a une expression avec les chapeaux
et sans les chapeaux d'expression or
avec les cigares et sans les cigares je
n'ai jamais
jugé crit comme acteur
je pense que sur lui après tous les
filles qui a fait
c'est pas un grand acteur
c'est un grand metteur enceinte
pour le premier film il est réveillé
dollars et
un billet d'avion
un touristique pour le deuxième des 5 5
4000 dollars et
deux tickets première classe
[Musique]
pour le troisième des million il était
explodé comme un grand star
international
[Musique]
en 1975 je suis allé au studio Warner et
j'ai passé plusieurs heures à parler
avec Clint en tête à tête pour une
interview quand vous êtes seul avec lui
vous ressentez le charme la
décontraction et l'intelligence dans
tout le monde parle à son propos mais
que vous ne voyez pas toujours à l'écran
dans ces rôles
ensuite lorsque j'ai commencé à écrire
sa biographie et que j'ai commencé à
rencontrer des gens dans sa vie ils se
sont mis à me raconter une histoire qui
était bien différente du mythe et de la
légende de Klimt
[Musique]
volons à la recherche de la légende
direction San Francisco où il est né
pour comprendre le mythe Eastwood il
faut traverser un immense continent aux
terres inexploré cette Amérique profonde
c'est le jardin de Clint il a tourné la
plupart de ses westerns et c'est là que
vivait ses ancêtres
[Musique]
les bartolomiaux sont les arrières
grands-parents de Clint dans leur
épicerie du Colorado on trouvait de la
nourriture et des outils
l'arrière-grand-mère de Clint Sofia
était une pionnière de ses nouvelles
terres elle participe ici à une réunion
de femmes dans l'état du Kansas
[Musique]
son mari Charles Runner était en même
temps homme d'affaires comédien et
musicien il possédait un restaurant
c'était une version ancestrale de Clint
art et business était dans leur gêne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
San Francisco c'est la ville de Clint
celle de ses origines il revient
toujours
à sa naissance il était déjà une vedette
le bébé le plus remarquable de la
maternité
il est né en 1930 dans un hôpital de San
Francisco il faisait 5 kilos alors les
infirmières la connaissance parce qu'il
était le plus gros bébé de la maternité
et quand elle faisait des réunions avec
les mères pour leur apprendre à changer
les couches Clint servait de mannequin
il était le mannequin cruche
[Musique]
dans les années 30
nous avons retrouvé une des maisons ou a
vécu la féministe food lorsque Clint
avait 12 ans au 107 inside Avenue
Clint a toujours affirmé avoir vécu son
enfance dans des quartiers ouvriers mais
en vérité il appartenait à une famille
bourgeoise assez privilégiée et fut
scolarisé dans de très bonnes écoles
comme ici le lycée technique deck
[Musique]
le mal l'héritier du nom de famille et
il était ce beau garçon que sa mère
aimait porter dans ses bras pour le
montrer aux voisins en leur demandant
n'est-il pas beau mon fils
en grandissant il entendait toujours
combien il était beau je crois que ça a
été un grand facteur de son succès de sa
confiance la manière dont il marche son
allure sa façon de s'adresser aux gens
le physique percutant de lecteur va se
manifester pleinement dans le rôle culte
de l'inspecteur Harry
[Musique]
tous les films de la série ont été
tournés ici dans les rues de San
Francisco
[Musique]
nous louons une voiture et laissons le
volant au journaliste Jim van burstirk
qui a écrit un livre sur les fictions
réalisés dans cette ville siphotogénique
il nous guide vers les lieux mémorables
ou furent tourner les films de Clint
Eastwood
quand j'ai écrit ce livre je savais que
de nombreux films avaient été faits ici
mais quand j'ai commencé mes recherches
je me suis rendu compte qu'il y en avait
des centaines tournées à San Francisco
ou supposés se passer à San Francisco et
tournait ailleurs
je crois que le fait que Clint Eastwood
soit né à San Francisco se ressent dans
ses films
ses meilleurs effets que ce soit à son
côté sombre ou son côté le plus beau
il sait comment travailler dans les rues
pour mettre en scène sans Francisco et
faire de la ville un personnage à part
entière de ces films
pour les films qu'il y a fait
[Musique]
j'ai appris une histoire intéressante
peu connue à propos de l'inspecteur
Harry à l'origine le scénario a été
écrit pour Frank Sinatra l'action se
passait à New York
Frank Sinatra a refusé parce qu'il
s'était blessé à la main et le pistolet
était trop lourd pour qu'il le porte
alors ils ont proposé le rôle à John
Wayne et John Wayne l'a refusé en disant
je ne prends pas les restes de Frank
Sinatra
alors ils ont demandé à Clint Eastwood
et à sa demande l'action a été située à
San Francisco
c'est un rêve de cinéaste de faire des
films ici
la nuit tombe sur San Francisco
finissons la journée par la visite d'un
ultime lucullte
l'île d'Alcatraz sur laquelle se trouve
la prison où fut tournée un autre grand
succès de l'acteur Clint Eastwood
L'Évadé d'Alcatraz
[Musique]
le lendemain matin nous prenons la route
du sud vers Los Angeles le long de cette
côte californienne j'ai le nez de lieu
qui ont marqué l'histoire de Clint
Eastwood
[Musique]
comme l'immense base militaire de Ford
il fut appelé à 21 ans pour aller faire
la guerre en Corée
et à cause de son physique et parce
qu'il nageait bien il a obtenu le job
certaines personnes pensent que c'est
son premier entraînement en tant
qu'acteur parce qu'en tant que maître
nageur il prenait des cours pour
apprendre à parler aux gens et savoir
comment se mouvoir dans des situations
données c'était donc une phase de
maturation
mais tout ça est aussi arrivé pour lui
éviter d'aller en Corée car il y avait
cette guerre sanglante beaucoup de
soldats étaient tués et le fait d'être
maître nageur lui a permis de ne pas
aller au front
pour prendre du bon temps à Carmel la
petite station balnéaire voisine
militaire il venait à Carmel pour aller
en boîte de nuit
[Musique]
en Amérique Carmel est une ville fameuse
pour sa beauté pour ses plages
quand Clint devint riche il est venu
s'installer à Carmel où il a acheté une
maison ouvert un restaurant
le restaurant était connu dans son
cercle d'amis comme un endroit où Clint
pouvait rencontrer des filles alors
Carmel est réellement je pense la ville
de son cœur
[Musique]
changé depuis cette époque et ça reste
le fief de Clint il possède un golf des
maisons un ranch
[Musique]
quand il devint célèbre il avait même un
tournoi de tennis à son nom et surtout
selon son en politique comme son ami le
président Ronald Reagan il fut élu maire
de la ville en 1986 et le resta pendant
deux ans
de la ville nous ouvre ses archives
voici une de ces affiches de campagne
de points de vue sur la façon dont les
gens ressentaient la candidature de
Clint Eastwood au poste de mer
je crois que le fait qu'il était une
vedette de cinéma à enthousiasmer la
population il était résident depuis
longtemps alors je pense que les gens
d'ici le connaissaient ou le voyait à
son restaurant ce fut une époque
excitante le taux de participation était
élevé et il y avait des équipes de
télévision du monde entier pour couvrir
l'élection
[Musique]
il est là très officiel je trouve
il est connu pour ne pas préparer ses
discours et pour parler spontanément
la raison pour laquelle je vous ai sorti
cet album et pour vous montrer notre
brochure Clint Eastwood se présente à la
mairie
on peut y lire je me présente comme mère
parce qu'il y a d'importants problèmes
vitaux que doit affronter notre ville et
je sais que je peux aider à les résoudre
[Musique]
la presse du monde entier a fondu sur
Carmen pour couvrir l'élection de Clint
Eastwood ils ont firent les gros titres
et pas certes totalement à côté de ce
qui se passait vraiment en fait il avait
une aventure amoureuse avec une autre
femme ma théorie est que Clint voulait
être maire de Carmel pour ne pas rentrer
chez lui c'est quelque chose qu'il a
fait souvent dans sa vie lorsqu'il se
lasse de la femme avec qui il est il se
construit une vie alternative ailleurs
nous comprendrons plus tard ce que veut
dire le biographe
voyageons à nouveau le long de
survacifique
nous suivons une des plus belles routes
du monde la Tétouan entre camel et Big
Sur
cette côte une beauté préservée Clint
est située l'action de son premier film
en tant que réalisateur
un frisson dans la nuit en 1971
passe à la mise en scène fut une étape
cruciale de sa vie
[Musique]
plus au sud dans ces collines arides qui
domine l'océan habite un homme très
secret
un homme important dans le parcours de
Clint Eastwood
leur collaboration se terminait par des
procès
il vit aujourd'hui retiré dans une
grande propriété isolée loin du monde et
de l'univers du cinéma
[Musique]
Jérémy crunsberg écrit le scénario et
les chansons de doux dures et dingue
sortie en 1978
il garde dans son bureau des souvenirs
de ce film un peu décalé il s'agit en
effet d'une comédie la première fois que
clean te sait risqué en tant qu'acteur
alors que le monde entier l'identifié
encore à l'inspecteur Harry
là il va partager le premier rôle avec
un singe et contre toute attente ce sera
le plus énorme succès commercial de
toute sa carrière
[Musique]
j'ai essayé de vendre mon scénario
toutes sortes de gens 47 personnes l'ont
refusé avant qu'il arrive à Clint et un
jour le téléphone sonne ma femme répond
et me dit c'est Clint Eastwood oui Clint
Eastwood
s'est présenté il a dit j'aime beaucoup
retenio voulez-vous venir m'en parler
il était très amical je n'avais aucun
problème pour communiquer avec lui
là c'est Clint et moi sur le tournage
dans le Colorado on discutait une des
scènes
je crois que Clint connaît Clint eastwo
très bien mais il n'est pas un comédien
il ne comprend pas la comédie dans la
comédie vous faites monter un gag et
vous ramassez le bénéfice à la fin
par exemple il y a une scène devant un
feu de camp dans laquelle Clint fait des
confidences
il dit quand je rencontre une fille je
me transforme en gelée royale une vraie
gélatine et la caméra recule
et vous découvrez qu'il parle à un singe
il ouvre son coeur un singe ça c'est un
gag
j'ai eu des soucis avec celui-là on
était dans une limousine pour aller sur
le lieu de tournage et Jim Fargo metteur
en scène dit aux cameraman on commence
avec un plan de Clint et l'orang-outan
j'ai dit attendez vous ne pouvez pas
faire ça parce que si vous montrez
d'emblée les deux personnages il n'y a
pas de scène vous avez dévoilé la chute
la plus grande star du monde à cette
époque ou presque tout le monde avait
peur de s'adresser à lui mais moi
j'allais frapper à sa porte et je disais
Clint il faut qu'on parle parce que je
voulais que le scénario soit le meilleur
possible
je pense que ça la fâché et quand nous
sommes arrivés à Denver dans le Colorado
ma ville d'origine fritzman qui était
son producteur associé est venu me voir
pour me dire Clint ne veut plus te voir
sur le plateau Jérémy
j'ai réalisé que Clint n'aimait pas
affronter les gens il ne vous regardera
jamais droit dans les yeux pour vous
dire qu'il est fâché
il fera les choses par derrière laissera
quelqu'un d'autre faire le sale boulot
il ne vous attaque jamais de front il
joue ce rôle dans ses films mais il
n'est pas comme ça dans la vie
[Musique]
par la suite j'ai découvert qu'il avait
réécrit toutes les chansons du film j'ai
découvert qu'il avait invité tout le
monde a une grande fête au Texas pour
faire la promotion du film et je n'étais
pas invité
finalement nous avons été en mesure de
trouver un arrangement légal pour nos
désaccords arrangement signifie qu'il
vous donne plus d'argent qu'ils le
veulent mais moins que ce qu'il faut
doivent
le film a connu un tel succès que ça m'a
aidé et beaucoup appris
sentiment je ne suis pas du genre à
broyer du noir ma vie est trop belle
alors je lui souhaite d'aller bien et je
suis sûr qu'il a beaucoup à faire avec
lui
[Musique]
je n'étais pas payé par la production
alors j'ai fait un procès Clint
est arrivé devant la cour pour faire sa
déposition le juge lui a demandé
vous pourriez me donner un autographe
et j'ai regardé le jeu et j'ai regardé
clean il m'a regardé et tous les deux on
a éclaté de rire
et c'est la dernière fois que je l'ai vu
[Musique]
roulons vers Los Angeles sur la fameuse
route US 101 qui traverse d'immense
plaines agricoles quand il était enfant
la famille de Clint parcourait ses
routes pendant la grande dépression
économique des années 30 son père
cherchait du travail aux quatre coins de
la Californie
[Musique]
il n'existe quasiment pas de photos des
parents et de l'enfance de Clint qui les
garde dans sa possession et verrouille
cette période de sa vie
mais en 1982 il a réalisé un film sur
cette époque
conquis donc man
[Musique]
c'est aussi de cette expérience nomade
que naquie sûrement le good Eastwood
pour les rôles de déracinés de cowboy
errant sur des terres sèches
nous sommes en approche finale de Los
Angeles
succession un terminal de banlieue sont
venus se fixer des missionnaires les
colons les chercheurs d'or des migrants
et des cohortes d'ambitieux en cas de
gloire hollywoodienne
Clint Eastwood fait partie de ses
rêveurs anonymes lorsqu'il avait 20 ans
a brisé bien des mirages mais elle a
aussi mise en orbite des stars pour
l'éternité
[Musique]
après notre journée en terre
californienne nous pénétrons deux nuits
dans la cité des anges et dérivons sur
Sunset Boulevard où s'exhibe le business
du spectacle
le rayonnement de Clint Eastwood perdu
son dernier film vient de sortir et
envahit l'espace publicitaire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
depuis les années 60 Clint Eastwood
règne au pays du cinéma
cyclint est un monument historique son
parcours fut toute une histoire
tout a commencé ici après son service
militaire Clint est venu tenter sa
chance et Hollywood et il fut remarqué
par un metteur en scène homosexuel nommé
Arthur loubine qui réalisait des films
pour le studio universel il avait craqué
sur la belle gueule de Clint son maître
95 et son allure d'athlète déglingandais
[Musique]
à Hollywood et devenu acteur reste
assimystérieuse on dit Arthur Lubin est
allé voir Clint dans une station-service
où il travaillait elle lui a proposé un
contrat pour rentrer chez Universal dans
l'école des jeunes talents
sur cette photo du début des années 50
nous voyons Clint assisté à un cours ou
Malon Brando était venu à la rencontre
des étudiants
[Musique]
le sujet du premier essai était très
dramatique très intense et clinique n'a
pas convaincu il était sans expérience
alors une des assistantes d'Arthur
lebine a une autre idée mettons-le en
maillot de bain très moulant filmons-le
et posons lui des questions
[Musique]
de viande c'est un des aspects amusant
de sa personne j'en parle dans mon livre
il aime au thé ses vêtements dans ses
films il est souvent nu dans une
baignoire et il a enlevé sa chemise vous
savez ce n'est pas le cas de toutes les
stars masculines
alors très tôt cet ancré dans sa
psychologie l'idée qu'il est si beau
torse nu devant une caméra qu'il va le
refaire tout au long de sa carrière
même maintenant qu'il a plus de 80 ans
et aussi quand il en avait 70 il joue
des personnages de vieux qui ont du mal
à tenir debout mais qui dans les scènes
importantes quand les méchants
s'enfuient soudain il court aussi vite
que
c'est toujours exhibé physiquement c'est
une part importante de sa psychologie
parce que c'est pour ça qu'il a été
remarqué à ses débuts Arthur Lubine m'a
dit il était très beau c'était un
magnifique morceau de viande
[Musique]
il veut apprendre la comédie
sous contrat avec Universal il prend des
cours de boxe avec l'entraîneur maison
il décroche des petits rôles dans des
films de série B tels que Francis dans
le Navy ouvert près de choc
heureusement durant ces années de galère
Clint avait trouvé une petite amie
sérieuse qui le soutenait
quand clean il voyait beaucoup de filles
et rencontra sa future femme Maggie qui
était une étudiante
n'était jamais allé à l'université mais
ils se sont reconnus immédiatement
quand elles sont venus à Los Angeles
elle avait un meilleur job elle était
mannequin pour maillot de bain
ils ont surpris tout le monde en se
marient si vite le jour de Noël 1953 à
passa des mers
[Musique]
il ressemble à deux mannequins très beau
très jeune
et sur ces photos il semble très
amoureux
les jeunes mariés vont s'installer dans
une résidence située au cœur de la
vallée de Sant Fernando non loin des
studios universels
est une foule de jeune plein d'ambitions
[Musique]
c'était un endroit très festif
tous ces jeunes gens couraient après un
avenir doré c'était une population très
normale des buveurs de bière
[Musique]
klins émet beaucoup les femmes
dès leur installation à la Villa Sanz
Maggie dut affronter une vaste
concurrence
[Musique]
toutes sortes de gens vivaient là comme
ses amis de l'époque m'ont dit qu'il
sortait avec de très nombreuses filles
et qu'ils sont vantés en privé quand ma
Guy n'était pas dans les parages
certaines étaient relativement célèbres
comme Jeane Mansfield
quelqu'un m'a raconté qu'un jour elle
est venue à une fête à la vie de la
Sands dans une tenue très voyante Clint
et elle s'éclipsèrent pendant un moment
ensuite clintra compte à que Jane et lui
avait pris du bon temps dans une autre
partie du modèle
en ce temps là chez les Eastwood c'est
Maggie qui ramène de l'argent
malgré une vie agréable et apparemment
insouciante au soleil de Californie
Clint RAM
Universal ne renouvelle pas son contrat
il fait un peu n'importe quoi des rôles
mineurs
[Musique]
le voilà en 1957 dans la série de
télévision wespun Story à cette époque
il envisage de renoncer à faire l'acteur
mais il s'accroche et suit les cours de
théâtre d'un coach appelé Jack Goslin
qui devient son mentor alors la chance
va tourner
[Musique]
des gens avec commencer à voir son
potentiel il avait été très bon dans
quelques petits rôles dans ses cours de
théâtre il était parfois très
impressionnant il faisait des
improvisations il en mettait plein la
vue à tout le monde alors il avait été
remarqué mais publiquement il
n'émergeait pas
du coup il pensait sérieusement à
abandonner quand se présenta une série
télévisée une histoire de cow-boy
appelée lowride il décroche à l'un des
deux rôles principaux en fait le second
rôle cette série connue un succès
immédiat et entra dans le top 10
jouait le rôle d'un gars tranquille mais
qui montrait son courage lorsque vous
aviez besoin de lui qui avait beaucoup
de charme qui plaisaient aux femmes
il connaît un très grand succès avec
Raize
la carrière de Clint s'accélère et
surtout il commence à très bien gagner
sa vie
dès lors il peut investir il achète une
maison sur Beverly Glen
[Musique]
la maison ou Clint eaguis se sont
installés à l'époque existent encore
caché dans un chemin un haut des colline
qui domine la vallée c'est une période
heureuse
Clint goutte son nouveau statut de
vedette
il fait de la promo pour hide ici à Las
Vegas avec une starlette une
collectionne les jeux des filles comme
la championne de natation en Italie
ou fin de les ignorer
[Musique]
avec certaines des petites amies de
Clint dans les années 60 quand je
faisais des recherches pour mon livre la
plupart d'entre elles l'aimaient
beaucoup et trouvait qu'il était un
excellent partenaire pour faire la fête
était l'une d'entre elles avec son ami
gilbaner elles étaient des fêtards de
notoire à Hollywood dans cette bande de
noctambule avec qui elle sortait on
croisait des gens comme Elvis Presley
[Musique]
Hollywood à l'époque
réellement une double vie la vie d'une
vedette de télévision heureux en mariage
tandis qu'en privé il vivait une vie
débauchée avec différentes petites amies
l'une d'elles était une cascadeuse qui
faisait de petits rôles dans l'eau hide
avec elle Clint avait une relation
sérieuse elle s'appelait Roxane Tunis
tout le monde sur le tournage savait
qu'ils étaient ensemble certains
savaient même qu'ils avaient un enfant
ensemble le soir Clint rentrait chez
Roxane promenait le bébé dans le
quartier lui disait au revoir et ensuite
il rentrait chez Maggie dîner avec elle
et ressortait pour faire la fête toute
la nuit avec ses copains
la vie de Clint est tellement compliquée
qu'il fera de l'enfant à sa maîtresse
avant d'en faire quelques années plus
tard à Maggie
voici une photo de la fille de
clinteroxane Kim Burt Unis né en 1964 la
presse ne révèlera son existence que 20
ans plus tard
rowride fut donc une époque clé dans la
construction de la légende de Klint
mettre suffisamment d'argent de côté
pour ne plus jamais travailler mais au
lieu de ça Sergio Leone est arrivé il
cherchait un acteur américain de seconde
zone pour jouer dans un spaghetti
western de série B Clint avait envie de
progresser de passer à un autre niveau
il voulait faire autre chose que il a
accepté le job
c'est ainsi en prenant ce risque majeur
que Klint sue saisir sa chance et qu'il
devint une star mondiale à partir de là
tout lui réussit il enchaîne les succès
essentiellement avec des rôles de
cow-boy le voici avec le réalisateur
tête poste sur le tournage de pendez-les
haut et court elle est recrute venue lui
rendre visite
le voilà sur le plateau du film Les
Proies avec une autre fiancée durable sa
partenaire Johan Harris
mais il se lance aussi dans les rôles de
flics tels que l'inspecteur Harry qui
consacreront sa gloire sur le tournage
il devient complice avec l'un des plus
brillants réalisateurs des années 70
donne Seagal qui va lui enseigner le
métier
cette triomphe lui valent d'accéder au
plus haut niveau du Panthéon au lieu de
sur cette photo historique il pose entre
autres avec par brasse présente Rock
Hudson John Wayne et Yves Montand la
trajectoire de Clint est fulgurante et
fait de lui l'un des hommes les plus
puissants et les plus riches de
l'Hollywood et certainement le dernier
géant de l'époque doré où les stars se
nommaient Malon Brando
James Dean
ou Marilyn Monroe
parvenu au firmament Clint reste marié
avec Maggie les voici lors de son 40e
anniversaire avec leur premier enfant
Kyle qui vient d'avoir deux ans
il va même lui faire un deuxième enfant
une fille Alison qui naîtra en 1972
ce que Maggie ignore c'est que Clint a
de nombreuses relations extra-conjugales
et que certaines sont si stables qu'on
pourrait parler de polygamie
Hollywood nous avons rendez-vous avec
Sandra
locctrice avec Kikine s'est mis en
ménage en 1975 bien qu'il soit toujours
marié à Maggie leur histoire d'amour
durera près de 15 ans et finit en
séparation à la dure avec deux procès
très médiatisés elle en garde une donc
contre son ex et précise pourquoi elle
accepte de parler aujourd'hui
tellement de mal de moi dans les médias
depuis qu'on s'est séparé
il a tellement plus de relations et de
pouvoir que moi pour faire ça
il a dit des choses sur moi elles m'ont
blessé personnellement et
professionnellement
c'est pour ça
ou lui faire la guerre ou dire des
mensonges
c'est juste pour parler de ce qui m'est
arrivé et pour me présenter
Sandra a écrit un livre pour raconter sa
mauvaise expérience avec Clint elle a
osé le défier devant la justice la banni
de l'univers du cinéma
est certainement une icône il reste
probablement une des grandes dernières
stars les plus glamour
à part ça sur un plan personnel je n'ai
pas grand chose de bon à dire sur lui
[Musique]
nous roulons vers sa maison cachée en
haut d'une colline
elle se rappelle sa rencontre avec Lindt
en 1975 sur le tournage du film Jessie
well sur la loi
[Musique]
dans l'Arizona c'était vraiment très
beau
oh mon dieu les lacs le ciel c'était
juste un endroit magnifique très
romantique
[Musique]
ça a été un coup de foudre entre nous il
est arrivé sur un cheval dans son
attirail de Josy Wells il avait une
barbe dans ce film vous en souvenez
sûrement
[Musique]
c'était un moment magique parce qu'il
était ce cow-boy emblématique à cheval
je crois que nous étions tous les deux
très amoureux pendant longtemps on était
très heureux ensemble tant dans
longtemps
il m'a demandé de l'appeler papa il
était comme une grande épaule je le
percevais comme un roc quelqu'un sur qui
je pouvais toujours compter
il était bien plus âgé que moi et donc
la dynamique que nous avions durant
toutes ces années et la raison pour
laquelle ça marchait si bien
c'est que j'étais l'enfant et il était
le père
Maggie de plus en plus étrangère à la
vie de son mari a déménagé avec ses
enfants à Carmel
lorsque clean rencontre son bras et
s'installe avec elle dans la maison de
Beverly Glenn Olivet auparavant avec
Maggie
je ne me sentais pas bien là-bas parce
que c'était resté exactement comme
lorsque Clint et Maggie avait vécu
j'aimerais avoir une autre maison j'ai
trouvé une autre maison sur stradelarode
c'était une jolie maison moderne du
genre hispanique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans l'immense résidence privée de
Bel-Air ou demeure stars et millionnaire
nous avons retrouvé la maison de
stradelarode
difficile d'imaginer ce qui se passe
derrière ce portail mais son Drake nous
a prêté une vidéo amateur tournait à
l'époque où elle vivait avec Clint au
début des années 80
[Musique]
ce balcon c'était juste des lattes de
bois alors j'ai fait fabriquer tous les
piliers
[Musique]
il y avait un mur
ensemble plusieurs lits et j'ai fait
faire la boiserie par un fabricant au
Texas qui l'a fait pour moi
j'ai tout fait moi-même j'ai trouvé
chaque morceau de tissu chaque meuble
j'étais amoureuse de chaque centimètre
carré de cet endroit
à se présenter comme mère de Carmel
c'était qu'il possédait ce restaurant Le
hoxing il voulait faire construire un
building juste à côté
mais ça dépassait la hauteur que la
municipalité autorisée alors ils ont
refusé son projet
[Musique]
je me souviens qu'il m'a dit
je vais faire ce que je veux
si je dois diriger la ville je vais le
faire
il a dit je vais être candidat à la
mairie il s'est présenté et il a été élu
je crois qu'il a construit son building
comme il le souhaitait
j'ai écrit autre chose dans mon livre
une anecdote nous arrivions de Los
Angeles en avion nous allions atterrir à
Carmel
et il a dit regarde en bas c'est Carmel
c'est mon royaume
une autre fois on était à Washington
quand Regan était Président on était
dans une limousine il faisait nuit et on
traversait la capitale tous les
buildings étaient allumés c'était très
beau et qui t'a dit regarde ma douce
Karine m'appelait ma douce tout ça
pourrait être à nous et j'ai pensé au
nom je ne veux pas je peux imaginer que
ça arrive mais je ne me vois pas dans ce
scénario
on était très amoureux c'était génial
mais je ressentais ce besoin de faire
quelque chose par moi-même à ce stade
la relation a commencé à changer quand
j'ai commencé à réaliser des films
je voulais mettre en scène et je lui ai
dit j'ai trouvé un scénario bad boy
Pinta senti qu'il perdait le contrôle
sur moi il y avait comme une menace dans
le fait que je commence à mettre en
scène
je m'éloignais de cette relation père
petite fille actrice réalisateur le
cocon dans lequel j'avais vécu il est
devenu de plus en plus distant à ce
moment-là et il disparaissait soudain ne
me disait pas qui quittait la ville et
après j'apprenais quand je rentrais à la
maison qu'il était à Carmel
c'est la fin de l'histoire une fin
qu'elle va apprendre de façon brutale en
découvrant la face cachée de Clint un
dessin il a fait envoyer une lettre par
son avocat mordonnant de ne plus revenir
à la maison et disons que les serrures
avaient été changées
que mes vêtements étaient dans un
garde-meuble et que je pouvais aller les
chercher
et j'ai eu l'audace quand il m'a
interdit l'entrée de la maison de
prendre un avocat je voulais récupérer
ma maison sa maison Sandra ne la
récupérera jamais malgré des procès
contre Clint au cours desquels elle a dû
affronter la violence des avocats
et en plus elle n'est pas au bout de ses
surprises
j'ai reçu un appel téléphonique d'un
journaliste qui écrivait pour la presse
people
il m'a demandé connaissez-vous une
maison à telle adresse à Carmel
[Musique]
elle est au nom de l'homme d'affaires de
Clint j'ai dit non je ne connais pas
nous avions une maison à un autre
endroit Carmel et il a dit bon
a une autre femme dans cette maison et
il a deux enfants avec elle
quand j'ai appris ça
j'ai juste pensé mon Dieu
où il a changé du blanc au noir où j'ai
vécu avec quelqu'un que je ne
connaissais même pas
[Musique]
déçu par son géant Sandra avait besoin
de dire ce qu'elle avait sur le cœur
c'est seulement elle est tombée de la
nuit qu'elle accepte de nous faire
visiter l'intérieur de sa maison
actuelle
chargée d'histoire et de souvenirs
[Musique]
c'est ma maison maintenant et c'est mon
genre de décor
j'ai fait beaucoup de choses ici qui
sont similaires à ce que j'avais fait
dans la maison de Stradella
je suis très heureuse de l'avoir recréé
pour moi
[Musique]
merci d'être venu
vous pouvez voir un peu Hollywood au
loin
Hollywood scintille et Clint dans les
années 90 après avoir quitté sombre
allocs
sa domination
désormais sa vie de monarque sera pavé
d'honneur et d'héritiers
alors que sa maîtresse une thèse de
l'air nommée Jocelyne Reeves vient de
mettre au monde deux enfants et légitime
à Carmel
il rencontre l'actrice française Fischer
avec il se met en ménage et à qui il
fait aussi un enfant
[Musique]
il fait tourner français dans le film un
pitoyable
c'est la consécration suprême car en
1993 Clint reçoit pour cette œuvre
l'oscar du meilleur metteur en scène et
celui du meilleur film
une victoire partielle car ses perles
lui accordent pas l'Oscar du meilleur
acteur
celui-là il ne le gagnera jamais
en revanche sa vie privée est un
feuilleton rebondissement
[Musique]
1993 lorsqu'il faisait la promo du film
impitoyable il a rencontré une jeune
journaliste de télévision appelée Dina
Ruiz il a été subjugué par elle il a
commencé à l'avoir en secret même si en
principe il était encore avec française
Fischer
est allé aux Oscars pour impitoyable
française Fisher était enceinte de lui
mais il ne voulait pas qu'elle le dise à
qui que ce soit
français se ficheur a vite été mise sur
la touche alors qu'on voyait Clint de
plus en plus souvent avec dinar Ruiz
trois ans après il l'a épousé ils sont
mariés en 1996 à Las Vegas ils sont
restés mariés et heureux ensemble
jusqu'à présent pour ce qu'on en sait
[Musique]
Clint a eu ni exactement avec combien de
femmes il en a eu un quand il était
encore lycéen j'ai raconté cette
histoire ensuite il y a Kimber la fille
qui l'a eu avec Roxane Tunis et puis il
y a les deux enfants qui l'a eu avec
Maggie sa première épouse et puis il y a
les deux enfants qu'il a eu avec
Jocelyne Reeves quand il était maire de
Carmel et puis il y a Francesca la fille
de française Fisher et puis il y a
Morgan la fille qu'il a eu avec Dina
Ruiz j'ai entendu parler d'autres
possibilités quand je faisais mon livre
depuis son mariage avec dinar Ruiz et
qu'ils ont eu un enfant ensemble je ne
pense pas que la presse est mentionnée
d'autres femmes à ce jour
[Musique]
avec Dina Ruiz la carrière de Clint est
entrée dans son apogée
il obtient une véritable reconnaissance
professionnelle il est couvert d'honneur
dans le monde entier la critique signale
régulièrement des chefs
entre autres sur la route de Madison en
million de l'art baby en 2004
[Musique]
Gran Torino en 2008
en presque 60 ans de carrière à
Hollywood Clint est passé de figurant à
monstre sacré